The untamed beauty of the Galapagos has fascinated and inspired people for centuries,...
...but an outdated diesel fuel power plant threatened the fragile ecosystem...
...with excessive CO2 emissions and the constant risk of fuel spills.
To preserve this World Heritage Site,...
...Ecuador imposed a policy of zero fossil fuels on Galapagos.
Global engineering companies were invited to come up with alternatives.
The remote location and the 100% carbon neutral requirement...
...were proving to be major challenges.
But Siemens wasn't about to give up.
The team's ingenuity, driven by a passion to make a difference,...
...resulted in a game-changing solution.
In 2018, the Isabela Island Hybrid Power Plant...
...became a pioneering model for clean power.
Based on 100% renewable energy,...
...it combines solar power and biodiesel with a battery storage system,...
...a world first for a local energy solution...
...helping to preserve the Galapagos Islands' unique beauty for future generations.
It's time to care.
Creating environments that care.